This is very nice. That building is very nice, eh? It's beautiful
This looks like my studio. I've come
to MIT a number of occasions and I've
been mostly
fascinated by the participants or the students
I guess you would call them.
These people are in a situation where
they have to find out
how to create the future.
Little Sun is a way of holding hands
with the Sun. The project is about
our ability to take something which is
incredibly abstract like understanding
energy
and then make it somehow tangible.
It has a solar panel. It has batteries on the
inside
to store the energy and it has a small
LED to emit the energy as light.
There are 1.6
billion people in the world without
access to electricity
it's very much but energy poverty. It's
about lack of development opportunity.
The work of art in my mind is not
necessarily this piece of plastic
it's much more the whole system of
working together with different entities
and people on the way taxes bring it to
finally rural users in a chain which will
ideally have
a number local profits in it on the way
When we had discussed bringing Little Sun
to MIT, it was because I have strong
confidence
in the sort of resonance between why and how
When people say something about how
they wanna do something
you can sometimes inside of that or
underneath that you can see why
Make it simple. Simplicity is crucial
The idea should like an elevator pitch
Hacking Arts is a festival and hackathon exploring the intersection of
art entertainment technology and
entrepreneurship
Little Sun is really such a perfect
example of the type of thing
That we want to encourage here.
With the hackathon you get a chance to work on something, change it, see it in a different way
Little Sun is going to be really fun to hack on.
What we're proposing is a community that centers around a website
that's going to help the people who are involved in the
selling and distributing of Little Sun to do three things
To explore, to connect and to join
There is a lot of
components about the project Little Sun
which are very much about
social communities, infrastructure
The ability to
make choices for yourself, being
independent, saying
I'm gonna take the Sun and empower
myself and I'm gonna read
tonight. I'm going to educate myself.
That could be a title
What? The Infinite Corridor, and it's taken, but
The Infinite Corridor... did I make that?
No that's their title for this space... because it's so long
Ah, the Corridor
My work has tried to, in various ways
address this question of
is reality actually real? By being
real is it then relative and is it
construction? Could I change it? Could I
change my world?
Do what I do have an impact on my
surroundings?
Can I feel that impact or it just a
theoretical impact so
all those questions and if you think
about it Little Sun is right in there
in the heart of all these questions.
What we are doing with Little Sun is we actually making a real impact for people in rural areas
We were curious about what visualizingthe
global community around Little Sun would look like
In looking at the globe with the pins sticking out
it brings awareness of
the collectivity of it
You need something in between theory and
action, which of course could be called
MIT
(laughter)
Here the opportunities are immense
I mean the power of MIT's is far beyond the
power of any company that I know
and so I see that collaboration take
forming many many shapes
Electric circuits, material expertise
Is it battery expertise? Is it business
expertise?
I do think we need to start to
Treasure what creativity is capable of
now we're sort of
in an engineering environment. I really encourage and
suggest that you would reach out
and ask creative people. And that my slow
you down. It might take you on a detour
but generally speaking I really think
it's worth it
Creativity is the success of the
consequences that a choice
has. So T choose between red and blue but that
is not the creative choice
the creativity in the choice between red
and blue is the impact that this choice
has on the world
And you really only make these
creative
choices once you are inspired. See
now
I would say that is a skill that one can
nurture
I think in the first idea has a lot of
potential
in, for instance off grid in building
community
Well thank you so much for... No thank you!
A great amount of the success up MIT has
been its ability
to lean out into other fields and I
would encourage this to continue
into the arts, into the dances, into the
writers and theaters and ballets and music
and so on
This is, I think, one of the solutions in
which we can create a lot of change